wären wir ja alle noch warten wurde der
44 jährige arzt christoph kuhlmeier
jetzt bereits in england als einer der
ersten deutschen auf jeden fall geimpft
und das wollen wir natürlich einfach von
ihm selber wissen gestern gegen 19 uhr
war es soweit und heller tag x die erste
frage natürlich wie fühlen sie sich
jetzt einen tag nach der impfung merkt
man überhaupt irgendwas ist alles essen
sollte der arm zu ganz leicht wie man
merkt dass man eine spritze bekommen hat
so wie bei der grippe schutzimpfung aber
wirklich dass wir bisher keinen ebenso
gucken keine müdigkeit keine
irgendwelche schlechte sachen also
wirklich alles und bisher
momentan auch vor allem risikogruppen
geimpft also über 80-jährige und auch
schon medizinisches personal
wie genau sind sie dann jetzt so früh in
den genuss wenn man fast sagen der
impfung gekommen war das weil sie auch
selber hausarzt sind oder wie kam es
dazu dass sie gestern abend die spritze
bereits bekommen haben
ja das war genauso also wir in england
werden auch die über 80-jährigen erstmal
oder der höchsten priorität dem es dann
auch bald die kleinsten altenheime und
pflegeheime aber das wurde jetzt im
krankenhaus sind joel gestartet der
ganze der ganze prozess und am
freitagabend waren aber noch 700.000 um
zwei paketen die sind ja 975 pro paket
da drin und da waren nur 7 100 dosen von
dem zweiten paket übrig sodass
leiterrahmen bei eine meldung raus kam
an alle hausärzte krankenschwestern in
der gemeinde arbeiten das doch bitte um
acht uhr morgens am samstag angerufen
und dann kann man sich schon vorstellen
sind drei telefonnummern und dann
plötzlich waren diese telefonleitung
doch sehr belegt denn finden leute
wollten sich impfen lassen wenn er noch
gut durchgekommen nachmittag und habe
dann meinen von gästen haben also
ungefähr sechs uhr englischer zeit 7 uhr
deutscher zeit erhalten und jan hille
war alles toll
heißt es denn dann dass diese dosen dann
tatsächlich alle verbraucht werden oder
muss man sich das so vorstellen dass
wenn bis zum bestimmten zeitpunkt eben
diese dosen nicht genutzt werden dass
das dann hinfällig ist also die müssen
ja bei uns wird angegeben innerhalb von
dreieinhalb tagen oder offiziell sind es
fünf tage seit dem 1
die dosen aus dem gefrierschrank kommen
müssen innerhalb von fünf tagen
verbraucht werden bei uns sind auch die
gazelle dreieinhalb tage damit man noch
etwas mit der logistik zeit hat und da
man natürlich keine verschwendet also
dass er absolut ruhig mal wenn man jetzt
auf 500 dosen verliert obwohl so viele
leute darauf warten dann ist das höchste
priorität dass die an leute
weitergegeben werden und dann haben sich
ganz viele leute gemeldet die die haben
wollten und es stehen noch einige daten
die noch nie auf der ersatzliste sind
also das nächste mal wenn das passiert
da sind noch einige im
gesundheitsbereich und im pflegebereich
jetzt drauf arten sind in deutschland
heftige debatten darüber wie das sein
kann dass nicht nur großbritannien
anfängt sondern auch eben die usa und
andere länder
und man fragt sich warum bei uns
eigentlich nicht und wenn man diese
frage so stellt ist mir passiert in über
twitter zum beispiel dann sagen viele
jahre aber vielleicht ist das ja noch
gar nicht sicher und vielleicht ist es
besser wenn erst mal andere länder das
versuchen und deutschland nicht wie es
der ihre wahrnehmung ist ist doch alles
richtig geprüft oder nicht genau also
ich natürlich kein experte eben
impfstoffen in dem sinne sondern ich bin
hausarzt aber ich habe da vollstes
vertrauen dass das auch gleichzeitig von
den behörden geprüft worden ist und in
dieser prüfverfahren sind ja parallel
abgelaufen während die versuche
stattgefunden haben und das sonst dauert
das niveau das er nacheinander gemacht
und diesen fall hat man das steuer nicht
mehr nebeneinander laufen lassen und das
war schon sehr gut und ich habe da
vollstes vertrauen dass man das doch gut
geprüft hat und dass man da sobald man
das sagen kann man weiß natürlich nicht
was in zehn jahren vielleicht sein
könnte aber ich habe da vollstes
vertrauen dass das so sicher ist wie es
nur sein kann wie in deutschland also
noch immer auf die impfung warten
rutschen wir auch gerade in den nächsten
harten lockt dann ab mittwoch verfällt
deutscher wieder in einer tiefschlaf in
england sieht das ganz unten
anders aus wenn sie jetzt beide länder
beobachten was sind da für sie die
größten unterschiede wie man jetzt mit
dieser krise umgeht
12 wir hatten ja ein personen partiellen
locker und bis vor zehn tagen ungefähr
dann sind wir jetzt dieses drei stufen
systemen zurückgegangen und meist länger
als stufe 2 aber wir erwarten dass
vielleicht doch noch weitere
einschränkungen kommen mögen der
premierminister breite wohl etwas vor in
der kommenden woche dass da vielleicht
noch etwas geändert wird
also es ist schon interessant zu sehen
dass deutschland jetzt mit den härteren
lockdown rangeht wären wir doch einige
erleichterungen hatten ist schwer
abzusehen hatte die fraktion zahlen sie
in den letzten tagen wir uns auch wieder
hoch gegangen und mich würde nicht
wundert dass mir nach weihnachten wo es
lockerungen auch gibt wieder in den
wesentlich schärferen locken werden
vielen dank herr doktor kohlmeyer für
diese einblick als einer der ersten
deutschen der jetzt also die impfung
gegen das virus provision alle neidisch
auf sie kann man sagt 21 tagen muss ich
noch mal ran denn man kommt für die
zweite dosis dann wir wünschen auf jeden
fall alles gute vielen dank und einen
schönen dritten advent ihnen noch mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren